wir sind mitten auf einer boulevardbühne
im Theater am Dom und Michaela schaffrad
ist hier hinter dieser Tür eine Sekunde
Moment Michaela ja bist du hier ja ich
bin
hier hallo tchen das freut mich aber ja
mich freut auch habt ihr den Weg ins
Theater
gefunden das ist ja schwierig nicht nur
hier hinter der Theater ist versteckt
hier mitten in den opernpassagen
bitteönk haben eine ganze Menge Leute
gefunden das ist gut ja die Kölner
kennen das
jamen genau wo sind wir denn eigentlich
hier wie wo sind wir hier ja was ist das
das ist die Wohnung von Philip Karl und
Harald ach und du bist da irgendwie
reingeraten in das Schlamassel ich bin
czilia und ich bin die Nachbarin und mch
die ganzen Jungs ein
bisschen danke W die hier gibt keine
Garderobe hier wird es einfach schmeiß h
auf schmeter genauter genau pass auf da
ist dein Platz danke wie ist die Lage
sehr gut sehr entspannt äh ich habe ja
schon eine tolle Begrüßung gehabt durch
Dich und wieso soll es mir schlecht
gehen ich sitze hier im Theater am Dom
in dem Theater in dem ich im Moment
spiele wir spielen zurzeit ein sehr
erfolgreiches Stück hier die zärtlichen
Machos und ich freue mich schon wieder
auf heute Abend wenn es losgeht fühlst
du dich hier wohl auf der Bühne ist das
ich meine du hast ja vorher mehr TV Kino
gemacht äh Theater ist ja dann noch mal
was ganz anderes das stimmt Theater ist
was ganz anderes und ich fühle mich
wahnsinnig wohl auf der Bühne ich habe
meine Leidenschaft dafür entdeckt meine
Liebe dafür es ist einfach ein ganz wie
soll ich sagen ganz ehrliches handfestes
Handwerk
das tolle ist dass man direkt sein
Feedback bekommt vom Publikum entweder
währenddessen ne wenn die Lacher richtig
sitzen oder wenn die irgendwo Lachen wo
sonst noch nie einer gelacht hat es
kommt auch schon mal vor und natürlich
dann am Ende wenn der Applaus kommt wie
war der erste Auftritt
schlimm
aufregend mir schossen so viel Gedanken
durch den Kopf und ich hatte irgendwie
immer Angst dass mit dass der Text nicht
sitzt und D dass das vor allen Dingen
alles sitzt von von den Bewegungen von
die zur rechten Zeit am rechten Ort zu
sein aber es hat alles wunderbar
funktioniert und jetzt mittlerweile wir
spielen heute die 81 Vorstellung ist
natürlich eine gewisse Routine mit dabei
das ist klar was aber auch sehr schön
ist und was einem das ganze natürlich
extrem erleichtert weil jetzt kann man
auch viel mehr experimentieren wie
experimentiert man ja indem man einfach
bisschen was anders betont oder sich
auch mal anders setzt sich mal anders
bewegt indem man einfach menschlicher
wird weil der Text ist ja jetzt
abgespeichert da irgendwo da oben und
jetzt vermenschlicht sich das Ganze so
also man man spielt das jetzt gar nicht
mehr sondern man lebt es und das ist
natürlich ideal wenn man an eine Rolle
ist oder lebt wie ist das dann mit so
jemand wie Hansjürgen Bäumler zu spielen
den du wahrscheinlich als kleines Kind
noch
ja ja natürlich bei der Eiskunstlauf WM
gesehen hast ich meine wer kennt
hansjungbmler nicht ne also ist ja
wirklich
mit Marik Kilo ist eine Legende den
kennt ja wirklich jeder und das
natürlich auch über die deutschen
Grenzen hinaus weil sie waren ja auch
zweimal Weltmeister wenn ich jetzt
richtig informiert bin und mehrmals
Europameister und es ist sehr angenehm
mit hansjen zu spielen genauso wie mit
Mischa oder mit dem mit dem Mo also
Mogens vado ich habe wirklich drei
fabelhafte Kollegen an meiner Seite die
mich auch manchmal wie die Prinzessin
behandeln ja ist das nicht so wenn man
ja nicht erstmal ursprünglich nicht von
der Schauspielerei kommt wobei
Hansjürgen kommt auch nicht von der
Schauspielerei er hat aber
Schauspielunterricht genommen was viele
ja auch gar nicht wissen aber Hansjürgen
hat wirklich eine richtig klassische
Schauspiel und auch Gesangsausbildung
gemacht wann hat er das denn noch
gemacht relativ zeitig also nachdem er
ausgestiegen ist beim Eislaufen hat er
sich dann auch wirklich ganz intensiv
der Schauspielerei gewidmet aber du
nicht also du h gewiet aber du hast
keine Ausbildung gemacht nee ich nicht
also bei mir lief es eher nach dem
Prinzip learning by doing also
ich habe wirklich das große Glück gehabt
mit sensationellen Schauspielern oder
auch Regisseuren zu arbeiten wie WM
Wenders z.B oder tieter pff war einer
der ersten mit dem ich gedreht habe zwei
Filme sogar und er ist echt so ein
Mentor für mich gewesen der hat mir sehr
viel beigebracht und dann schaue ich mir
halt auch sehr viel bei den Kollegen ab
was ich wenn ich halt da auch nicht im
Bild bin bin ich trotzdem gerne am Set
mhm um zuucken wie die anderen das
machen und die lassen sich dann nicht
mal abtropfen so nach dem Motto ja geh
du mal weg du hast du hast ja keine
Ahnung also es gibt ja so vollbut
Schauspieler die wirklich keine Ahnung
ich weiß es nicht nee also die sind mir
bisher noch nicht begegnet nee überhaupt
nicht also bisher war es immer sehr
locker und und und angenehm und auch
sehr kommunikativ ja ich dachte es
werden zum Teil so chorifanen die so so
durch die Gegend schweben vielleicht ist
es auch nur ein Klischee ja ist n ein
Klischee kann gut sein also mir ist
einer also diese Art noch nie ja ja also
alle nett und okay und nicht das
manchmal hört man ja so zickigkeiten
untereinander und gar nicht also selbst
unter unter den weiblichen
schauspielerinen also mit denen ich
bisher gedreht habe habe ich mich
fabelhaft verstanden ich glaube es kommt
aber auch immer so ein bisschen darauf
an wie man selber in den Wald hinein
brüllt so schal ja dann auch heraus und
ich würde mich jetzt mal als relativ
umgänglich bezeichnen kontaktfreudig äh
ähm ja locker entspannt äh
vielleicht auch ein bisschen lustig
angenehm du bist unkompliziert ja könnte
man so sagen also ich würde mich als
unkompliziert bezeichnen ich habe zwar
auch hier und da so meine kleinen Macken
die jeder Mensch hat weil niemand ist
vollkommen aber ich glaube man kann
damit recht gut leben bei mir welche
Maen sind
das ich rede manchmal schneller als ich
denke was sagst du dann na ja das sind
dann halt so Sachen wo man dann im
Nachhinein so denkt so oh das hät mal
besser nicht gesagt oder was red hast
denn jetzt gerade hier für ein Blödsinn
geredet aber ich habe mir das
antrainiert also das kann man sich ja am
trainieren also früher war es schlimmer
bei mir mittlerweile denke ich erstmal
drüber nach und spreche dann aber wenn
ich halt irgendwie in der
wirklich bränzligen Situation bin oder
verärgert bin oder einfach sauer und
stinkig dann plappere ich halt dann
trotzdem manchmal drauf
los was bin ich denn
noch
da müsste ich jetzt echt überlegen ah
keine Fehler doch habe ich mit
Sicherheit ich war früher auch oft
unpünktlich das habe ich mir aber
mittlerweile abgewöhnt weil ich hasse
Unpünktlichkeit also ich selber hasse es
auch
ich habe es auch immer Gast unpünklich
zu sein manchmal hat nicht so ganz
funktioniert ich weiß auch nicht das hat
auch viel mit mit Zeitmanagement zu tun
und das habe ich aber mittlerweile auch
im Griff und ich liebe es pünktlich zu
sein am besten noch 5 Minuten vor der
Zeit ist das Mauras Pünktlichkeit ne und
also es gibt viele Dinge die man sich
wirklich angewöhnen oder antrainieren
kann aber ansonsten müsste ich jetzt
wirklich
überlegen was sagt denn dein Mann ich
glaube der findet mich
toll gut gemeiner gemeiner was sagt denn
dein Exmann das weiß ich nicht ich habe
nicht mehr mit ihm geredet aber der wird
ja was hat er zum Schluss gesagt ich
glaube das sollte man nicht in Ö nein
nein nein wir haben uns ein guten
getrennt so ist es nicht aber man
schließt natürlich in seinem Leben dann
noch irgendwann ab und es gibt halt
Menschen die kommen und gehen im Leben
ja wie so oft und ich
kann gar nicht schlecht über meinen
Ex-Mann sprechen würde ich auch nie
tun wissen was der schlechtes über dich
gesagt also nichts dass ich wüsste es
sei denn er hat irgendwas gesagt aber
das ist mir nicht zu gekommen gibt es
denn weil du hast ja ein ich sag mal
bewegtes Leben was erstmal in eine ganz
andere Richtung gegangen ist du warst
Pornodarstellerin GI gibt es Leute
trotzdem die dich durch die ganze Zeit
begleitet haben die das alles mitgemacht
haben sagen ja me meine familieine
Familie auf jeden Fall also die haben
wirklich alle Höhen und Tiefen erlebt in
meinem Leben wofür ich Ihnen auch sehr
sehr dankbar bin dass sie mir trotzdem
wo deine Mutter hat nicht von Dir
erfahren na ja das stimmt gut
informiert ja also es war nicht schön
wie meine Eltern das damals erfahren
haben das stimmt dass S jaals über
Dritte erfahren das war natürlich schon
ein großer Schock für sie aber ich sage
immer nur sprechenende Menschen kan
geholfen werden und wir haben über das
Thema gesprochen und ich habe ihnen
damals meine meine Gründe dafür
erklärt und sie haben es akzeptiert und
das finde ich ganz ganz toll dass meine
Eltern sich nicht von mir abgewendet
haben sondern sie gesagt haben du bist
alt genug wenn du Entscheidungen triffst
dann musst du auch dann mit den
Konsequenzen leben wenn es welche gibt
und das ist dein Leben und du musst
daraus das Beste machen natürlich sind
sie heute wesentlich glücklicher und
sind natürlich extrem stolz mich auf der
Theater Bühne zu sehen und den Erfolg
mit mir zu feiern und Freunde gibt es da
welche die das so die ganze Zeit
begleitet haben und alles mitgemacht
haben oder hat sich das immer wieder
verändert also haben sich welche get
getrennt von dir weil es war ja relativ
spät war erst mit Ende 20 dass du das
gemacht hast
die sich in der Zeit quasi von dir
abgesetzt haben wei sie das gar nicht
oder wie war das gibt kann man trotzdem
so eine Kontinuität also es gibt ja
wenige Menschen die ein so das ganze
Leben begleiten bei mir ist es zumindest
so ja also bis auf meine Familie ist es
auch wirklich nicht so dass ich jetzt
sagenn ich habe jetzt von Anfang bis
Ende eine Freundin gehabt ich habe aber
letztes Jahr eine Schulfreundin wieder
getroffen mit der ich sehr eng
befreundet war zwar habe ich da ein ganz
witziges Format für RTL gemacht 30
Minuten Deutschland heißt das und da
ist ein Kamera h mit mir also in meine
Vergangenheit gereist also in meine
Kindheit und Jugendzeit Schule und so
und da haben die meine alte Freundin aus
der Schule echt ausgegraben worüber ich
mich tierisch gefreut habe und auch
meine alten arbeitskolleginen vom vom
Kinderkrankenhaus damals in Stollberg
die habe ich auch wieder getroffen und
das war ein ganz schönes und auch
tränenreiches
Wiedersehen und den Kontakt haben wir
jetzt wieder aufgefrischt ja also jetzt
ist der Kontakt wieder da und der wird
auch jetzt gehalten also da haben wir
uns gesagt wir sehen uns jetzt wieder
öfter oder mindestens einmal im Jahr
machen wir so ein come together ist das
nicht so dass man sich dann auch über
die Jahre sow weit auseinander lebt weil
man eben so viel anderes erlebt hat dass
man sich da nicht nichts mehr zu sagen
hat also nee also ich finde im Leben
passiert so viel
dass man sich immer was zu erzählen hat
und ich meine wir haben uns jetzt ja wie
lange haben wir uns wir haben uns jetzt
10 Jahre 11 ne 12 Jahre haben wir uns
nicht gesehen und in den Jahren ist
natürlich wahnsinnig viel passiert und
da ich hab bekannlicherweise gerne Rede
wird es eigentlich auch nicht langweilig
die anderen kommen nicht wor doch
natürlich ich habe ja anstam lass ich
lass die Leute auch reden und Ausreden
ja wenn du jetzt von heute an
zurückblickst dein ganzes Leben hast du
alles richtig
gemacht also ich glaube wer das von sich
behauptet
ähm dem kann ich keinen Glauben schenken
also ich glaube dass ich vieles richtig
gemacht habe aber hinterher bist du
natürlich immer schlauer und es gibt
auch Dinge die ich jetzt heute mit 40 so
wie ich heute hier sitze nicht mehr
machen würde weil man einfach viel mehr
weil man halt einfach die
Lebenserfahrung hat und weil man halt
auch die Konsequenzen zu spüren bekommen
hat aber du hast ja positive
Konsequenzen e also wenn wir jetzt noch
mal auf die Erotik
jainen
hintertche überallch aber ohne das W das
nicht passiert du es ist ein Teil meiner
Vita es sind zwei Jahre in meinem Leben
die kann man nicht so einfach
rausschneiden und das was ich mit 20
oder mit Ende 20 gut gefunden habe das
muss ich halt heute nicht auch noch gut
finden weil man verändert sich einfach
im Leben man entwickelt sich weiter und
damals fand ich das absolut in Ordnung
und heute sage ich na ja hätte ich jetzt
nicht unbedingt machen müssen aber es
ist ein großer Fehler mit der
Vergangenheit zu hadern ja
ganz im Gegenteil man muss einfach
lernen damit zu leben und auch damit zu
arbeiten eventuell oder es einfach zu
akzeptieren aber es ist auch eine Sache
die nicht mein Leben bestimmt nee aber
es hat ja auch du wärst ja nicht hier
ohne das hättest ja die Chance gar nicht
geh kinderkest genau und das ist das
einfach war wo ich sage man man lernt
sich damit zu arrangieren es ist ein
Teil meines Lebens und ich bin aber froh
dass ich es heute nicht mehr mache ganz
klar gut das ist ja auch ist das schönne
das jetzt ja ja klar anders
schöner es es erfüllt mich einfach mit
ganz viel Freude und es ist das also das
ist so ein absoluter Traumjob den ich
hier mache und ich meine wer kann das
schon von sich behaupten dass
man ja seinen Traumjob macht also das
das ist kann kaum einer wir haben das
oft dass ich mitm Hans jungen hinter der
Bühne stehe und und dass wir dann so
sagen WOW und dafür werden wir auch noch
bezahlt
herrlich super ja dann wünsche ich das
noch in der Zukunft ohne Ende danke
schön
super